To start this week's direct message with
a trigger warning.
That's right,
so take a moment,
get a design comfy,
and move carefully to your safe space
because we've got to talk.
I'll actually wait for
bit.
All right.
I think that did it.
Now that you've been triggered,
warranty Leah,
let's talk about free speech.
It feels like it's on the ropes these
days,
right?
Well,
we've been talking a lot about it here
in the context of how the regressive
stifled debate by calling everyone
racist,
sexist,
homophobic,
or the rest.
This very concept tolerance for
intolerance has been taking root at
college campuses across the country for
quite some time now.
There are two completely separate
situations unfolding right this very
moment.
One is on the campus of Yale where some
students were upset that a professor
wrote a letter defending the right to
wear offensive Halloween costumes.
The letter in part explained that you
can either ignore the costume altogether
or you can engage in the person wearing
the costume,
telling them why you find it offensive.
Apparently this wasn't enough for some
of the students culminating and video
that has now gone viral in which a
student's screams at the dean quote.
It's not about creating an intellectual
space.
It's about creating a home here.
The other situation is at the University
of Missouri where students were fed up
with a series of racially motivated
instances they felt weren't being
properly dealt with by the
administration.
The students demand to the resignation
of the president,
which he submitted after the mostly
black football team got involved.
A video on campus has also gone viral,
showing a young journalist trying to
cover the protest,
but being screamed at and bullied by a
group of students.
Ironically,
these students are trying to silence
someone who was only there to cover the
very protest that they wanted attention
for.
For one of the oldest and largest
journalism schools in America.
It seems that Mou has gotten something
very wrong about free speech.
Of course,
these two instances are not isolated in
America,
nor in other parts of the Western world.
Colleges and universities are the very
places you're supposed to go to engage
in the battle of ideas.
To learn new ways of thinking and to
challenge your preconceived notions.
Yet somehow colleges are the very place
that had become hostile to all of these
concepts.
Now shouting down speakers you don't
agree with demanding professors,
be fired for contrarian views and
denying the media free and unfettered
access have found their home in these
safe spaces.
Of course,
this all ties in perfectly with
everything we've been talking about on
this show.
The regressive left by calling everyone
racists and bigots and homophobes and
the rest have ushered in a generation of
people who were so sure in their beliefs
and so dismissive of their opponents
ideals that they have no reason to stand
up for free speech anymore.
If your opponent is a racist or a bigot,
then why even engage with them?
You've got the moral high ground,
so just shout them down or call them
until they give up.
These are the tactics.
The regressive have used successfully in
so many areas and now we're seeing the
fruits of their labor.
I want to be very clear here.
Nothing I'm saying is dismissive of the
actual issues these college students are
dealing with.
There is no doubt we have racial
problems in this country.
We have a quality problems.
We have wealth disparity problems and
the list goes on and on,
but these problems won't go away if we
don't talk about them.
They won't magically resolve themselves.
If we only talk to people we agree with
actually,
they'll only get much worse.
This is the inherent flaw of identity
politics that the regressives love so
much.
When you whittle us all down just to
race,
religion,
nationality,
sexuality,
or whatever else there is,
there's very little left to unite us.
I'd much rather look at people based on
their ideas and their beliefs.
Those are the principles that unite us
across the divide that the regressive
left has been digging.
I've been saying for awhile now,
the two things can be true at once.
In this case,
it can be true that these students have
legitimate grievances and at the same
time it can be true that free speech
shouldn't be sacrificed on the altar of
political correctness.
We should be more worried about the
government taking away our free speech
rather than us taking it away from
ourselves.
Some say the road to hell is paved with
good intentions.
Some say the ends justify the means.
Some just want to shut you up and that's
when you have to speak the loudest.
Joining me this week as a human rights
activist who grew up in a place not too
kind to freethinkers.
Currently he's the Middle East community
manager of movements dot Org and
organization dedicated to open and close
societies.
He also happens to be in Los Angeles for
the first time,
right?
This very second.
Feisal,
Syeda Macarthur who welcome to the show.
Who all affect you that hiring me.
I mean I thank you for bringing sanitary
towel overall.
I've been a big fan of your show since
it started,
so wow.
Saturday to all of the world.
I would say so because like I've seen
your video being shared of lexile.
I have friends who will live in in the
Middle East and and,
and they were all talking about you,
so it's certainly great to be here.
All right.
That's very rewarding.
We could probably on the show right
there,
we'll talk a little bit about you as
well.
So,
uh,
I want to talk about your personal story
and coming from Iraq and all that,
which is really,
it's really a wonderful story and it's
so a perfectly lined up with a lot of
things we've been talking about here.
But first I want to talk about how I
came to know you a because the second
episode that we did have this show on
Oprah.
I had Karen Santa Maria on and uh,
a few days before that she had been
tweeting that she was in contact with
someone that knew somebody in Saudi
Arabia that was outed as a secular list
or an atheist and was in trouble there.
Life was threatened,
I think by their father in your name
then got looped into this.
And then this is a direct through to
what you do@movements.org.
So can you just tell me a little bit
about that instance?
Yeah,
I mean that,
why it's a pretty
interesting case to say the least is
that so the man is,
comes from Saudi Arabia and uh,
and he,
he also happens to be a lucky one
because he does have an American
passport,
so he lives in the United States and he
went to,
like into a discussion with his father
on the dinner table and he told him he
didn't even say like,
he's an atheist.
He just said that he has some doubts
about God and things of that sort.
And the end result of that conversation
is that his dad had threatened him that
he's going to report him to the
authorities and that actually means in a
country like Saudi Arabia,
which is digitally death or you're going
to get flashed like our friend Dr.
but our,
um,
so far,
uh,
he started contacting a lot of secondary
organizations.
Like,
this is my story.
Um,
I'm,
uh,
I need help and things of that sort.
And he came across Kara and Kara made
that like she said like,
oh,
I have a friend who can have someone
inside Arabia and,
and I kind of became the direct person.
Uh,
somebody tagged me on the foot on the
post because that's my work that I try
to help activists in closed societies.
So basically carry tweeted something
saying I would like to help this person
but I don't know what to do and that's
where you jumped out.
I jumped in and I also jumped in,
in trying to verify his story is true.
And I went back and forth and
conversation with him to see a like if,
because I mean we have tons and tons of
cases and it's very important to know
which ones are true to case because
every case takes take long time.
Like nothing gets solved.
So I tried to make it too.
We have a vetting system in which we
make sure that these stories are,
are legitimate.
And then so what do you do?
Like what is the vetting system actually
entail to find out if this guy is
actually telling the truth and not just
somebody that wants to get out of the
country for other reasons.
Yeah,
I mean,
I mean somebody who is a refugee myself.
Uh,
there are certainly questions that
somebody can know whether this like you
can ask them specific questions about,
uh,
about what,
what they,
what did they say to their parents and a
weather like how is their relationship
with their parents,
you know,
if that is actually like his dad is
really crazy enough to report him to
the,
like to get his son killed.
Like it's a and try to see like what he
is trying to achieve.
Like why he wants to leave.
Like what are you trying to achieve when
he wants to leave and,
and things of that sort and try to
connect if he does no other circles and
other friends that go through his
facebook friends and started to see if
it says like I told this person and
tried to see if there's like the story
matches up.
Um,
for this story.
I mean,
I admit like I always spend few hours
because it's very,
was very emergent situation.
What we did is that,
uh,
because he got an American passport so
there was no visa,
like there's no visa needed,
so we crowdsourced,
we crowdfunded a money to get him to
United States.
So like within,
like I tell him like by,
by five,
I think like by 5:00
AM you have to be at the airport,
we only have like 12 hours and just make
sure that you're able to go to the
airport and within this 12 hours I'm
going to be able to crowd fund and get
you the ticket.
The ticket was waiting for him at the
airport.
Yes.
And how are you communicating?
This is done via email.
Well,
in some of these clubs societies,
they use apps like whatsapp and viber
and all of these stuff because they
cannot be controlled by the government.
Um,
and he does seem to be a bit of tech
savvy that he's able to use,
let's call vpn that the government
cannot track.
Whereas exact location is.
Um,
and also,
I mean,
here's what the crazy part about this is
that there is another case happened
before by a gal called Hamza coach
Carter,
and he also came out as an atheist and
he escaped in Malaysia,
which is so called moderate Muslim
country and the Saudi government
contacted the Interpol and got him out
of the airport there.
So Interpol,
which is a national or international
position to defend human rights and all
of that,
they stopped him and get him back to
Saudi Arabia.
So this guy,
because he got an American citizenship,
Kinda helps in getting him.
He went to Dubai and from why he went to
the United States.
Um,
so yeah,
that's,
that's a now he's actually,
he's in the United States and he's in
the united.
Yeah.
So that's a good success story.
Yeah,
it's a good success story.
And that's why I wanted to jump off
there with you because that's what you
guys do@movements.org.
It's a perfect example of technology
meeting something that's important
because you guys are literally raising
money to save secular people and
atheists.
Yen Not only money.
I mean,
so the whole system of movements.org,
so we crowdsource a human rights,
so what we do is we connect activist
from clubs,
societies to people in open societies
who have the skills to help them.
So it can be somebody who's looking for
a web designer and woman rights
activists in Afghanistan want to be
published in the media.
We have a partnership with the New York
Times,
the woman in the world.
We have partnership with the daily
beast,
the Huffington Post.
So we try to match what the activists in
this closed societies want with people
who are on the open societies who have
the skills to help these specific
requests.
So it's kind of like multi sided
platform.
There's request and that our offers.
And then our job is just get a match.com
for four skills,
uh,
and also have a partnership with people
who give organization.
They'll give grants to civil rights
organizations and things of that sort.
So that's like the main concept of
movements.
Yeah.
So how do you guys make sure that the
network of people that you're setting up
isn't being infiltrated either by
governments or other people that want to
hurt these people?
Yeah,
I mean what I mean,
there's very impossible to have 100
percent secure system.
So I'm going to be very honest about
this.
I mean even facebook and Google and all
of these,
but we.
So we have a vetting system in which
these people who sign up,
we ask them to put as much information
as possible to be able for us to be able
to verify this information.
And also we asked people from closed
societies,
and I'm going to go to the definition of
our societies afterwards,
is that to use anonymous,
uh,
names and like don't use a username that
does not reflect their,
like their actual location or the real
name for people who are in office
societies,
it's not really a big problem.
But for people who like live in Saudi
Arabia and in Pakistan,
in Iraq and all these places,
they would need to use a username and
they don't give an exact.
Like they don't say,
well this is my zip code and this is my
address and folks to please come and
save me,
but they can just make kind of a general
request.
And then within the,
within the messaging service that we
have,
they can reveal some of the information
and we also have a very strong security
in terms of,
of people trying to hock and things of
that sort.
And the organization started as a result
of funding from Google.
So we get that kind of saved in terms of
security.
We don't have a problem of like big
hacking and uh,
but yeah,
I mean it is,
it is.
It's obviously a possibility that many
of these governments,
whether it's Iran or Saudi Arabia,
would you try to use a,
uh,
but we can track whether they're tried
to message people and tell them like,
oh,
what you guys do and things like that.
So also we have the star rating system.
So for every user,
no matter how much we've verified that
information,
we put them on a star rating system from
like zero stars to five stars.
So we ask people a few,
you get messaged by somebody got zero
stars,
you this person,
watch out,
and if it's five stars like people like
the New York Times or having linkedin
post.
So that's.
So we,
I mean it's,
it is dependent on the user and we also
tried to make them cautious that they,
uh,
but as I said,
look,
you cannot prevent,
uh,
all types of attacks from this
authoritarian governments.
Sure,
sure.
So I want to talk more about the
authoritarian governance,
but a little bit more about your work
first.
How much is actually just trying to get
these people out versus connecting them
with people in the closed society so
that they can actually change their
societies from within.
Yeah,
I mean the fact of the matter is,
is that many of the activists,
we have one to do change it their own
countries.
There is a significant amount that
actually want to get out.
And getting out business is one of the
most difficult ones.
And I've been somebody who's a refugee
myself.
I had,
it took me around three years and I mean
I left Iraq.
I went to Lebanon from Lebanon,
I went to Malaysia and I had to wait and
then like from I left Iraq in 2009,
I would have to United States in 2013.
So it's like,
it's a four year process to actually
eventually move,
uh,
from a closed societies.
So most of the refugees or the people or
trying to save their life,
they go through like middle countries
like,
so because you're in your own country or
most immediate dangers of many people
will move to that clause countries and
their farm country countries moved to
the West.
So that is extremely difficult process
is that it's a.
But sometimes things change.
So for example,
one of the cases I've worked on is the
case of the Bengali bloggers and as a
result of we help publishing them at the
daily beast.
They were able to give that article to
the Swedish Embassy and received the
visa as a result because they told them
like,
look,
we are literally like publish it,
the mainstream media and,
and we are now in Sweden.
So is there a risk in a case like that
where these bloggers are writing in
Bangladesh where we know people are
being killed for this just in the last
two weeks,
several people killed.
Is there a risk that when you guys go
ahead and publish that either on daily
beast or Huffington post or wherever it
is,
that that brings more attention to it so
that suddenly there's this new crop of
people that didn't even know about it
that now now wants to kill them?
I,
I wouldn't think so.
I mean,
I mean as they say,
there is no such thing as half pregnant.
You're either pregnant or not.
Is that when,
when you.
I mean they're like a recent tweet by a
group called Ansara Islam,
which is the Al Qaeda affiliate in
Southeast Asia and they actually
published all the names of the bloggers
ask like.
So they actually stole our idea that
crowdsourcing terrorism.
Yeah.
So they like,
it's the reverse.
If they got something,
I got something there and they are
crowdsourcing terrorism is that these
are the names of the bloggers and this
and you should.
It's open source to everybody who wants
to go and kill them.
So many of us,
I mean it's,
it's,
they're already under threat,
so people,
when actually it's kind of helpful like
this,
I mean,
back to my case is that it helped me
that I was published in the mainstream
media in terms of getting known and it
will be easy for me to get a visa.
So if you are only published within
local news media,
most of the people who like know about,
like the lawyers and the staff will not,
will discount that.
They will say like,
oh,
we need something,
we can show it to American authorities,
like they don't understand Bengali or,
or do any of that sort.
So,
um,
so it is helpful to get published like
mainstream American media and all these
writers in La that just want to get
published for.
So they get picked up by an agent and
you're dealing with the same thing.
They're just by,
by language.
Yes.
And and Mac,
the concept of crowdsourcing is like,
so like in the case of Bengali,
so,
so he said they send this article in
Bengali and there is another person
translated Dr.
color from Bengali to English and there
was another person as is article and all
these people don't know each other,
everybody has a certain skill and then
there's the publisher.
So these three people work together and
they don't know each other,
help publishing the article and that
helped that getting somebody out to
Sweden.
So.
So that is.
So that's the concept of crowdsourcing.
Like everybody has a skill that they can
contribute collectively to great.
A great result.
Right?
So that's the beauty of it because
people think of crowd funding and when I
first went to the site and I was looking
around,
I thought it was really just going to be
about money,
like we're trying to raise x amount of
dollars to get this person out of this
country.
But really it's about the skill set and
linking people that otherwise couldn't
find each other.
I for,
for,
for a case like we talked about in our
Saudi Arabia,
we like,
so we depended on partnerships,
we're not actually the ones doing the
job,
but we could have the platform in which
all these people work together.
So the organization that did the crowd
funding was called recovery from
religion,
which is like a,
I think in Kansas or somewhere in the
midwest.
Uh,
and uh,
there is the funds there and so all of
us are connected together,
so the funds go to their and their users
from movements and.
Yeah.
So it's like a circle of people working
together to get somebody out.
Yeah,
it's incredible.
So in a case like this,
like this one that we're talking about
with Saudi Arabia where he had a.
So he had an American passport.
So you had an actual American passport.
Is this a case,
like why can't they just go to the
embassy then?
Why was he afraid to actually just go to
the American embassy?
I mean,
Saudi Arabia is supposed to be our big
ally,
right?
Yeah.
That's what these guys.
Sure.
Women can vote and all and can't drive.
But I'm not sure what the ally ward
here.
Yeah.
So why,
what would be the fear though of going
to the US embassy and claiming asylum or
something like that?
Yeah,
I mean,
um,
I,
I don't think that the embassies give a
protections because he's like a Saudi
citizen,
an American citizen at the same time.
And um,
I mean sometimes,
I mean even the,
these cases of like other other folks,
the US embassy doesn't seem to give that
much protection of from people
persecuted by,
as you said allies because allies,
right?
So yeah.
So that's what it creates attention.
So it's,
it's,
it was a better for him,
I mean just to leave the country and go
to,
to say to the United States other than
get a safe haven and he,
I mean even if going to go to the US
embassy is gonna still be in Saudi
Arabia.
So you're going to still be stuck inside
the embassy.
Do you have like a list of the
countries?
I mean,
I'm sure there's a master list of
countries that are close to you guys
call them,
but what are the countries that are
really the most impossible for the
secular released or the free thinker or
the atheists are all that yo?
Well,
I mean,
what we depend on the definition of free
society.
Our society come from an organization
called Freedom House,
so freedom house trucks,
all the countries in terms of freedom of
expression,
freedom of press,
freedom of association.
So they have like all the countries and
they're trying to put a try to do
reports on a basis to see which ones get
advised.
So which one got worse?
So I mean,
when it comes to the worst,
I mean our to put Saudi Arabia as the
worst.
I get our allies,
our,
yeah,
our favorite ally,
Saudi Arabia and Pakistan and Iran.
I mean that's,
I call them the axis of evil.
But uh,
so that's an.
I mean obviously North Korea,
but that's,
I mean it's,
it's,
uh,
I mean being anything in North Korea is
a problem.
Whether that being a believer in the
supreme leader of the leader of North
Korea.
So,
so North Korea is probably like the
closest yet society we know we know of
at the moment and I think there's a
Tajik start talking about Stan in
Central Asia and uh,
this is kind of like the most difficult
and also it depends on the strength of
there's something called strength of the
passport.
So like for example,
me as somebody who was an Iraqi Iraqi
passport doesn't get me anywhere.
Like there are only few countries that
get me in without a visa and that's the
countries I went to Lebanon in Malaysia,
like when I applied to United Kingdom
they rejected me saying that they
require like thousands of pounds in my
savings account and touch for six
months.
So yeah really.
So it's very difficult for countries
that have,
that.
They required a lot of,
like they require a visa for every
country they go to a to leave that
country.
But,
but for countries like which are in the
Gulf region,
sometimes it's easier for them to get a
visa elsewhere.
So there's,
the passport also plays a role in how to
get people out.
Yeah.
All right,
well that's a perfect segue to your
story,
which is pretty great.
So you grew up,
you were born,
interact and grew up in.
Yes.
Uh,
I guess we could now be referred to as
the good old days under Saddam Hussein.
I think of them as the good old days
kind of know right now.
I mean,
uh,
I mean it's surely,
I mean necessarily to use the word,
it's like it's a cluster fuck.
I'm his dad.
It's okay.
Yeah,
I mean I'm living at a living under
Saddam Hussein was,
was not really great.
I mean a w plus I was living under the
sanctions when Saddam Hussein was the
president.
So it was two things.
Those are two separate.
You had the regime itself?
Yeah.
The regime.
And you had the sanctioned,
sanctioned by the US and UK and
everybody.
Yeah.
And I mean it's literally a prison
living.
What was it like,
uh,
on any given day you're,
you're 13 years old,
what was it like?
Oh,
well,
um,
I mean you see his pictures everywhere
and you have to,
like when,
when you go to classroom elementary
school,
you'll have to stand up and say long
lifts.
Saddam Hussein,
when nine slash 11 happened,
he declared a holiday in the schools in
which my school was like praising the
mujaheddin did nine slash 11 because he
started like the faith campaign after
the Gulf War.
That's what,
there's a lot of confusion in which
they,
they conserve Saddam Hussein to be a
secularist.
His secular as compared to isis.
But that doesn't say much like probably
al-Qaeda's secular comfort diocese.
Was He really,
was he just using religion or was,
did you think he actually believed.
I mean,
uh,
it's,
I,
I don't,
I mean I'm not really good in
psychoanalysis but um,
I think that regardless of whether he
was using it for his own benefit is like
Iraq as secular as a.
sorry,
a just society.
So using religion is definitely a
beneficial to all of the people.
It cannot use religion to Sweden for
example,
but you're definitely able to use it.
Plus,
he built a lot of mosques and uh,
and he was um,
also,
I mean,
yeah,
I mean since the Gulf War,
I mean he started waging jihad against
the west and he start bringing people
like almost opposite became the leader
of al Qaeda and was he came to Iraq and
to like before the war.
And so yeah,
I mean,
um,
so for your life though,
so you're 13 years old and what happened
when were you having your,
sort of,
your secular awakening in yourself?
Well,
I mean the,
the lucky part of me is that I was
raised in a certain sort of liberal
family.
I call them cafeteria Muslims.
Um,
so my,
my dad was like said like,
Oh,
you can think for yourself.
And I was like,
I was reading the Bible,
the Old Testament,
the Torah,
the Telemundo and all of this stuff.
And all of that copy of the Talmud.
And well the Internet is,
even though it was like the Internet,
but there are some parts that you can
actually get online.
And I've seen that all of these
religions make objective of claims that
have them being true.
So I said,
okay,
well either one of them is through or
all of them are false and I moved like
start reading more about science and I
just realized that's probably like all
of them are false.
But my,
I would say like my spark do activism
came in after the war.
I mean when the first elections happened
in Iraq in 2005 and I was afraid of
that.
The sheer,
when they're going to take off the power
that Islam is a,
she,
I was going to take the power,
they're going to discriminate against
the Sundays and that would lead to a
civil war and that.
Exactly what happened.
I mean,
it's very sad to be right on this
subject.
A actually saw that coming.
You felt that?
Yeah,
I mean it was very obvious.
I mean the moment that Saddam Hussein
fell down the moment is when the shit
starts getting more.
Like they start getting more mobilized
and you can see pictures of Ayatollah
Sistani and mocked up the southern and
all of these little figures and it's
very obvious this,
these guys are sectarian.
And uh,
so I,
I said like,
well secularism is the literally the
solution is that try to make Sunni's and
equal under the law.
And we seen,
we seen that success happening when,
when the first prime minister I allow,
he was a secularist when he was the
prime minister.
There were much less sectarian warfare
happening,
but the moment where the election
happened is when Islam as part d sharp
too one and,
and w,
which is my biggest agreement with the
United States when it comes to you as
management of the water,
because I always thought that there was
not qualified yet for our democracy and
there needs to be some sort of
transitional period between building a
secular,
secular civil society and that will take
some time.
And then you created election,
not like after 40 years of dictatorship,
you would just make people who many of
them are illiterate,
would just go for a vote for the best
interests of Iraq.
So when we've seen many instances of
this as in Hamas was democratically
elected,
right?
Yeah.
The only example of a democratic is
another example of the majority of
people because voted for,
for a Muslim Brotherhood.
I mean one of the things of living under
a dictatorship,
but what I've noticed is that
dictatorships kill everybody with
disagree with them.
So people are left out,
are the,
are the ones who don't care about life,
so don't care about life that jihadists.
So dictatorships for a large extent
creates extra radical Muslims because
they kill all the moderates and they
then give the people a false binary
system is that either you want us or you
want the terrorists and the same thing
happening now in Syria.
So like with Assad,
his and now with the Russian
intervention,
most of what they're killing our,
the moderate troubles who are in the
middle.
So when,
when they destroy the troubles,
they're going to give the two choices
you want us or isis and I can assure
you,
most people including myself,
would choose us.
And,
and,
and that is exempt.
So dictatorships create extremism.
So what happens is that when these
dictatorships have go away,
they literally created like a hostage
crisis.
They created like a prison and you get
out of the prison and eventually you
would have continuous sectarian warfare
and continuous like bad politics and
America was obviously not very well
versed and dictatorship.
There were a lot of focus on like,
let's get rid of Saddam Hussein,
but there was very little thinking of
what after,
which is bostic Taylor.
She was much more important than just
getting rid of the dictator.
Right.
So where do you place or how much do you
place the blame on the United States?
And I guess at that time it was a
coalition that or at least originally
when of course it was mostly as because
I think most people in America now,
there's a real sense that it was the
wrong war to go to and they lied us into
the war and all that stuff,
which I do it,
but the sense I'm getting from you is
that there was a ton of really bad stuff
going on there anyway and a lot of it
maybe would have bubbled up.
Yeah,
I mean,
I mean there are so many things that
were like.
I mean,
Islamic extremism is done,
you it didn't,
it didn't start with,
with the United States and then started
with the CIA or Israel or the Mossad.
So these things have been have been
going on for hundreds of years.
So they send their conflict.
I mean it started in Iraq and back at
the time,
I don't think it was called,
but I mean now jeff and Kabbalah is
where mom,
Jose Hussein,
Ali were killed and that's where the
split between the Shia I think,
and then fast forward to the modern
history,
you got men empire who was at war with
the purchase of a weekend or the Persian
empire who are the and where the sun is.
So the conflict has been going on for
hundreds of years and all these
dictatorships and unsustainable.
Alexa was unsustainable and America did
not intervene in Syria until now,
recently after,
after the Messiah came back.
Is that,
is that still.
They still had the civil war between
Sunnis and Shias and they still had to
isis and al Qaeda and all of that stuff.
So it's,
it's true.
I mean,
I never thought that.
I'd never think that the United States
is the root of our problems obviously,
but I think sometimes that the United
States,
if some policies need to be applied
based upon the understanding of the
region that kind of prevent or reduce
amount of sectarian violence and that in
my opinion was to keep some sort of
transitional secular regime that can
build a civil society that can reduce.
I'm obviously it's not going to
eliminate a stickler.
So basically.
So basically if you had had a time
machine you would have gone back to
right around the elections when they
finally had the free elections.
Yeah.
And then you would have just sort of
either.
So you would have wanted either American
troops are saying they're to stay just
to stabilize it a little bit longer and
yet at the same time as an American,
even though I know it's all gotten worse
in these last three years since we out,
we didn't want to stay there either.
And that's.
I mean,
and the thing that I always go like
conversation with neoconservatives and
things of,
of people who believe consumers,
aggressive foreign policy is that is it
doesn't fit in with the American
political system is like an American
political ecosystem.
You have elections every four years and
like nation building,
you're talking about the Middle East in
which is,
which doesn't get done in four years.
It does.
Obviously it doesn't get probably 40
years,
so.
So it is unsustainable to have like a
political system in which the president
has to change every four years and
nation building,
especially in the region that is very
different,
let's say like Germany during World War
Two,
after World War Two and Japan as that.
Iraq is literally in.
It has the worst neighborhood ever have.
You have Saudi Arabia,
which is the,
which is the rule of the Wahabi regime
that's not that different from Isis and
you have Iran on,
on the east,
that is the mother lode of Shia Islam
and the is in the middle between between
and America was expecting like,
so come to Iraq and create a liberal
democracy in the middle of all regimes
that are theocratic,
that don't believe in liberal democracy
and,
and one of them is an ally,
which is kind of ironic,
is like,
so they try like now with the city,
they tried to work with non democratic
countries to create a democracy.
I mean it makes no sense.
Makes no sense.
It's like the idea that Saudi Arabia or
Qatar or,
or even Iran would allow a liberal
democracy to flourish in Syria and Iraq.
It's a pure delusion.
They're not that thrilled with the one
liberal democracy that's in the
neighborhood.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean,
well,
let's hope it stays.
I mean,
it seems to.
Seems like Israel is going,
uh,
I mean as,
as I can see is that there's a lot of
elements of theocratic a leaderships is
now rising up in Israel,
which is,
which may,
which I don't think I don't see Israel
content.
I mean I hope it's going to continue to
be liberal democracy,
but I see there are a lot of elements
that may not be in the future.
Yeah.
So against theocratic dictatorships and
theocratic routines regardless of
religion.
Of course.
A lot of people,
I think when I've seen,
I've watched things with you on Youtube
where people will attack you for,
they'll attack you being Islamophobic or
that you are attacking Islam or.
But clearly that's not the case.
Yeah,
I mean,
I mean the fact of the matter is like
you cannot see,
you cannot criticize Islam and Muslim
countries.
So even here in the west they created
some sort of like catch 22.
So if somebody is a,
as a white person,
like somehow.
So they immediately get attack him as
cisgender white male was of interesting
to hear to from like Muslims who don't
believe in science and so there.
But if you had to,
if somebody like me who is from the
Middle East looking to attack him as
some sort of uncle,
tall mass murderer.
So they kind of catch 22.
Is that in,
in the middle,
in the Muslim world,
you cannot criticize Islam and if you do
it in the West,
you will be credited,
you will be labeled immediately as a,
as some sort of greater as a trader.
Right.
So this is an incredible thing to me.
So I've had my new eyes on obviously.
Yeah.
I think,
you know,
magic,
right?
I am an acknowledgement of his latest
book.
So,
uh,
so,
you know,
have a little bit.
Um,
and he gets this all the time.
He gets it more than I do.
I think that he's a trader or he's an
uncle tom or he's a porch monkey.
I mean these guys.
And again,
we've talked about this a lot,
but this is coming from people on the
left.
So what I don't understand is if you
believe in liberal values and you want
women to be free and you want gay people
to be free and all those things and you
want a quality for everybody,
how do they expect to get it?
If not through people like you and
Magid.
Forget.
Forget Sam.
Okay.
They want to throw him under the bus.
What?
He's a great guy.
Of course I'm not for that,
but what I'm saying is if they want to
just remove,
they want to use their own version of
bigotry to remove him.
White Guy,
fine.
But then wouldn't they look at someone
like you that stands up for all those
values on the left and say,
this is a guy he survived living.
Sit down.
He now fights to make his country and
those other countries stand up for the
very values that we as progressives say
we're full.
And yet you don't get support out of
these guys,
do you?
I mean,
I,
I do get some but.
But I,
I know what you're referring to is that
the regressive left as much as no one
was.
Yeah,
I mean it's very interesting.
I called the unholy alliance that
happened between the liberal left and
the Muslim rights against the,
the or Muslim or secular left in the
Arab world.
And uh,
so ironically the secular left just to
put that altogether,
the secular left is actually lined up in
a weird way with the conservative,
the conservative.
Right.
Which is very.
Yeah,
it is extremely,
uh,
I mean they don't,
they don't say it very publicly,
but the fact of the matter,
I mean they apply extreme different
standards too.
And I was speaking at UC Berkeley before
I came here and I've had some debates
and in northern California and I told
him,
I'm like,
what do you call a conservative
Republican who is against gay marriage?
And he said,
I call him a bigot,
that he thank you for calling 90 percent
of Muslims bigots.
They said,
I never said that.
Right.
Okay.
Then I told him if you apply different
standards to different people based upon
their race and because they think that
Muslim is the brown technically,
right.
If you're not even raised,
uh,
if you have a few,
apply different people,
different sizes of,
based upon their race,
then you are actually a racist.
And this,
this form of racism is sometimes get
get.
Um,
because most of the racism we talk about
is like the KKK.
And the fact of the matter is that they
agree.
So like when,
when somebody like the Charleston
shooting,
the one habit in South Carolina is that
the guy said I'm motivated by racism,
and they immediately took him for his
word and they're true.
They're right there.
He's this guy who was motivated by
racism but replace,
replace this guy by Isis.
And Isis says,
I am literally motivated by this
interpretation of Islam.
The same guys who said that this game
was believable.
Racism will say,
no,
this thing has ulterior motives,
right?
It must be avoided.
Economics and foreign policy or politics
and George W Bush and Dick Cheney and,
and the Olympian,
older,
they create the solid of everybody they
hate and they put him in one category.
And so,
so you see like the double standards,
extremely obvious.
And uh,
so as a result of that they can,
you created a smokescreen for apologist
and,
and even extremists to flourish in,
in like people like me have to fight
against the religious right and the far
right in the United States who,
who consider me like inferior human
being,
right and,
and yeah,
and have to fight the religious right in
my own country.
That was lovely,
cried.
And then I have to find the apologists
left.
So like they created extra France for
and they,
they have made it very much,
very much difficult for people like
Majid Nawaz and many people who are
reformers to actually even have the
discussion to begin with because they
don't think there is any discussion to
be had and it's all about us foreign
policy and they always try to divert.
The discussion is all about America.
It's all about America.
And notice now,
now that I've more of these people
on twitter and there's probably a good,
maybe 40 people like yourself that are
trying to reform and coming from these
countries and trying to make things
better.
I see people like you tweeting about
coexistence,
tweeting about how do we make things
better.
All that.
And I never see it from the regressives
I,
yeah.
They always are screaming about foreign
policy or whatever it is,
defending our foreign policy.
That's,
that's not a binary system.
It's not a binary and yet.
So what is the angle?
What is it that they're throwing back at
you that they can't get behind what
you're doing?
Yeah,
I mean,
I mean they think that
the biggest problem.
So they see the world's consumption of
like a pyramid.
So the biggest problem in this world is
cisgender white,
male capitalist,
rich.
And then we actually defined cisgender.
I didn't know what it was until about a
month ago.
I made two.
I got to because I got to talk to
because of it is as a cisgender because
I'm cisgender.
Yeah.
It means that you were born at the
gender that you're central.
Yeah.
And that's now a privilege.
And I was like,
I come from Iraq and my brother was
killed and I told him that I'm
privileged,
but anyway,
so they,
they,
they have this pyramid in which there is
a,
they see the world based upon like race,
gender,
and,
and financial privilege.
And they think that the biggest problem
in this planet is western capitalism.
And uh,
they link everything unleash,
walled into.
It's a very American centric point of
view is that they link everything
problem in this world as a problem of
so.
So if,
if a,
if a brown person and from Pakistan
wants to blow himself up to say to
defend Jerusalem coat and a quote,
they will say that this is as a result
of imperialism happening by the military
industrial complex connected to western
capitalism.
So they always lump everything to that
and everything is an expression of
grievances.
So like you say,
somebody is like,
I hate Jews.
And they say like,
well,
I mean he doesn't actually hate Jews,
but that is his language to express his
first ration with American imperialism.
So.
So they always link everything back to
that.
Is there a,
is there the point is like,
and then I can tell people like nom
chomsky was like the head of the,
of the movement.
I would say I would have them on,
but I don't think he'd like to talk to
someone smarter than him.
Well,
I mean the.
I mean it's,
I don't think it's,
I mean Sam tried to engage with him and
it's a,
you can actually have a conversation is
that it's.
I mean they,
they seem to subscribe to a specific
dog.
Like I always tried to like make the
best of my friends that I can like
predict what Chomsky is going to write
just by seeing the title of the article.
So I like I make five points.
I say this is what Tom says going to say
in the,
in this paragraph and this paragraph.
And I always like get my $50 because I
with them,
I'm like,
what exactly Chomsky is going to say
that is about American imperialism is
going to say it's about the grievance.
This is going to say about capitalism
and all his like you don't need to read
all his books even though I've read
quite a lot,
but it seems like I've read two books
and all the rest were like,
just subscribe to the same.
So is that the danger of these guys
because what they're doing,
even if a certain percentage of what
they're saying is right about American
foreign policy.
I had Douglas Murray on last week.
Yeah.
Who I thought really said something that
I'd never thought of before,
which was that he said,
you know,
you Americans always think everything's
about you.
So what you're saying that's what these
guys are doing,
but let's just say a certain percentage.
I mean it's half truths.
I mean,
I mean many of them.
I mean look at,
for example,
what some apologists say,
is that what they say?
Like the majority of Muslims don't
support Isis.
This is true,
but it also doesn't support Isis.
So the question is,
do you support Isis?
Are Not saying not,
doesn't meet,
move you to the moderate.
Yeah.
You can subscribe to a lot of beliefs
that I said you agree with Isis with and
you don't need the support.
I says,
for example,
Ayatollah Khomeini,
harmony and all of the ayatollahs in
Iran,
they disagree with Isis,
but if you look at how they treat gays
in Iran is not that much different than
Isis,
so like the disagreement,
they tell you a truth,
which is the majority of Muslims don't
agree with Isis,
which is true,
but that's true if they don't tell you
that there's a significant amount of
Egyptians and Pakistanis and and and so
many countries around the Muslim world,
that thing,
that penalty apostasy should be death,
which is so I think like the purest that
has been done on like shutting on what
Muslims believe and I asked everybody to
read.
It was very intelligent because it asks
specific questions.
It doesn't.
People ask people like,
Oh,
do you support isis or not?
So this nine slash 11 or not.
But they ask him like no questions.
Do you think that suicide bombing is a,
is an appropriate way of dealing with
grievances and they use a significant
amount of saying yes,
and do you think it should be allowed of
killing these people who conspired with
new Americans?
And the Israelis will say yes and a
significant bonds will say yes.
So show that.
So when somebody says so,
all of these things,
even though some of the parts are true,
I mean,
as I said,
look,
I got us foreign policy in Iraq has not
been very great and uh,
just say the least and there are so many
things that should have been done that
have not been done.
And uh,
so yes,
United States foreign policy have a,
played a role in,
in,
in rise of the extremist in the Middle
East,
but they're not the root of the problem.
There is a huge difference between.
And there isn't like it was kind of very
ironic.
It's like the moment they agree,
like for example,
the abortion clinics that had happened
in United States,
they agreed that this is a result of
religious fundamentalism,
right?
Many of the Liberals agree that Mike
Huckabee and Ted Cruz and all of these
folks are motivated,
are Christian fundamentalists and they
are worried about them because they're a
Christian fundamentalist,
but the moment that this discussion goes
into Islam,
the moment that know the root of the
fundamentalist has nothing to do with
the tags,
has nothing to do with interpretation
and it's all about us.
It's immediately goes back and it's very
self center like egotistical point of
view is that everything is about the
United States.
It's not solving anything.
I mean I think that's actually a very
dangerous as you mentioned,
because they are giving a free pass to
these people that me and others who are
fighting on a daily basis,
they were fighting against the theocrats
in our countries and and,
and the,
the regressive light has given these
people a free pass to telling them,
well,
it's nothing to do with.
It's all about us.
Do you think they consciously aware of
it?
Because I,
I've sort of struggled with this
question a bit and when I've talked to
people,
I think a lot of people.
I think Sam at this point thinks that
they're fully malicious in what they're
doing.
I pretty much think so too,
but I want to give some of these guys a
little of the benefit of the doubt that
they're not doing this maliciously.
I mean,
it depends on,
on who are we talking about?
Um,
I,
I mean I think we need to mention names
here because every.
I did want to mention names,
but the.
I mean,
I,
I think that people like Nam Chomsky and
Frankenstein and some folks now I'm a
client I think are motivated by an
ideology that they actually cared about
which is left libertarianism,
anarchism against United States
capitalism and things of that sort.
There are people who are completely
disingenuous and completely dishonest
and they would,
Mr presents all of other people's views
like I was.
I was,
I think.
I think all my viewers probably know the
names that you're going.
There are people who like,
like for example,
I had a debate on which was featured on
NPR Wy and see I bought Islamophobia in
New York City and I said there are
progressive Muslims,
moderate Muslims,
conservative Muslims and extremists and
they our attacked as being generalizing
on Muslims and I said,
that is exactly what I didn't do.
Is that the,
that the statistics and the research is
being done.
It's to avoid generalizations is when
you say there's like 40 percent of
Americans believe in creationism.
You are literally saying that 60 percent
of them don't.
That is,
you're not generalizing on Americans,
but I kept repeating the same statement
and they kept saying that you are
generalizing all Muslims as extremists.
And I kept repeating and they kept
saying the same thing and then they,
they go in and,
and,
and take something out of context and
then they put that in a meme and shared
it on social media.
And somehow I started getting attack as
we generalizing all Muslims,
which is completely disingenuous.
So I mean,
what Sam has been dealing with is pretty
much what many of us who are actually
talking about this subject that I was
dealing with is that they are,
they're purely people are purely
disingenuous on the subject and the day
and actually it's kind of interesting.
I think that they want to create
something,
what I was telling you about Bashar Al
Assad,
which is to destroy all the nuanced
approach of the liberal critics of Islam
and try to create the battle between
them and people like Pamela Geller and
Robert Spencer and all of the far right
morons.
Yeah.
And so that way they will give people a
binary system and which they tell.
You know what?
So there was a war between far right,
fascist and Muslim medicine people.
So which side you can achieve.
I love that.
I love that framing because I,
I mean I'm getting email literally from
all over the world every day at this
point.
People talking about this middle ground.
Yes.
That's why I wanted to connect with you
and that's why I've been talking about
this stuff on the show because I don't
think most people are one side or the
far left or the far right.
Most people are right here.
Yeah.
I mean for the.
I mean sometimes I'm in on college
campuses.
It seems to me that the debate is also
like it's very polarized.
Like I and I was speaking at UC Berkeley
and Palo Alto and I,
and I'm speaking in Cornell and I spoken
so many universities before that I can
see that encompasses the debate seems to
be much more polarized and it's on the
media and the
and,
and I'm guessing it's a lot.
It's a lot of white liberals on the
left.
Yes.
It is upset with you.
It,
which is which is extremely,
so they always want to turn it up by
them.
I was like,
I,
I kept talking about like issues like to
honor killing in Iraq and things of that
sort.
And then a guy jumps up.
There has to be like a white liberal.
They are,
so there has to be this guy that was
gonna be.
This dude shows up at my venue,
uh,
whatever I go around this state.
So say no.
It's nothing to do with the culture.
It's nothing to do with the legendary.
It's all about us.
Don't you know about that?
Have you have to give me like the
lecture about the military industrial
complex.
Don't you know about Wall Street?
Don't pay taxes.
The so,
so none of the stuff.
You're not defending any of it.
Exactly.
There is no correlation.
I mean,
I,
like I,
I always mentioned this example is that
for example,
if somebody,
let's say a radical Muslim,
he walks in,
let's say a small town in Arkansas or
Mississippi and some redneck goes in and
calls them like a San Diego and like,
oh,
he faced any racism there.
And then this person,
the same person goes back to his house
and kills his daughter because she added
the guy on facebook.
These two actions are not related to
with each other.
Is that what some people think is that
this guy,
because he's facing oppression or racism
and some sort does lead,
let him to kill his daughter,
which something that he believed in
probably before he came to the United
States.
And so yeah,
and they think that everything is really
centered about oppression dynamics and,
and what's happening is that now you can
not even talk about the subject without
claiming to be a victim and it claiming
to be oppressed now.
Like the whole competition is that who's
the most victim and that's like I don't
really want to go to the identity
politics myself because it's like a very
crazy world is like all that.
Like now I look at websites like tumblr
or things like this and was like,
somebody identification is like,
it's not like,
oh I'm from there and I studied there or
whatever.
It's like I,
I'm transgender,
gender fluid,
a asexual,
this,
this is all about like his oppression,
like how much is oppressed and that is
what is now concerned the biography like
in some places.
So
at some level,
if you could lighten your skin and to
change your biography away from Iraq,
they'd like you a little bit more in a
weird way because they would think that
you're helping the oppressed.
Yeah.
Of somehow being from the place that
you're now betraying.
Like it's so warped.
Yeah,
it's very.
I mean that as I said,
like they,
they look at the wall,
the wall is pretty much like as a
pyramid and that's what like if you a
view blood like the critical race theory
and gender theory and it's pretty much
all about class,
gender and race and there's hardly any
mention of ideology and they.
So that's the way they see the world.
So is there anything that a brown person
is doing even though that his culture
that existed before the United States or
even Israel,
they say,
well this is as it as well of he's an
oppressed by the somebody else on the
upper class.
But there is a,
there are signs of hope.
I mean,
for example,
give me some hope.
We've got about eight minutes left.
Let's.
There are signs of hope strongly is that
people go to movements at Oregon,
they see like the continuous help,
like many of these activists are doing,
they're trying to achieve things in
their own countries because like when I
started becoming an and when I started
like being active as myself and,
and there were only very few people I
see on the Internet who are sacred are
free thinkers.
Now I look at facebook and social media
and I see tons of thousands from Iraq,
from Syria,
from Lebanon,
from all over the Arab world.
Countries like Malaysia has voted for a
secular country despite of all the
status quo of the region.
Is that,
is that many people think that the
Middle East is like one country.
If it's like things out of bad
somewhere,
it's bad everywhere else.
I mean places like northern Iraq,
which is a Kurdish region,
they seem to be much more developed in
terms of human rights,
uh,
than they have women on the ground
fighting Isis.
Yeah.
Then Turkeys bombing them.
That's a whole lot.
That's the.
I mean I've,
as I said,
there are signs of pessimism because
Turkey has a long secular history and it
is going backward with the but at the
same time there is a,
I mean I would say a very strong
position for the Argon in Turkey that
needs to be supported and that's,
and that's I think like if there's any
message I would give to the liberals is
like just don't betray us here.
Like the liberals in the way should
stand with their fellow liberals on the
east and,
and just start to apply standards and
should not stand with our enemies.
That's,
that's if there's a message I can say
just stand.
If you don't want to help,
just done,
don't stand with our lab.
Just make it easier.
Well I love that message and I love the
fact that you brought it also back to
colleges because that's where I started
the show today because we know we have
all this stuff with what's going on on
our yard to Missouri and yelled the
recent cases.
Exactly.
So that's what we were talking about
earlier and to me it's,
it's a direct extension of what these
guys on the left have done.
They've made everyone so intolerant.
Yes.
As you're saying that now it's sort of
like they are now reaping what they
sowed,
Yada.
It's kind of very interesting.
It's like it's a slippery slope.
They're like,
you're going to see over the moment of
time they're going to start at talking
to each other.
So it was,
it was a female,
the female white feminist or criticizing
male white feminists as being male
privilege.
Now the female is going to get attacked
by a transgender disabled person of
color.
You're the white tiles,
tiles,
gender nondisabled.
Uh,
so they're going to start talking to
each other and eventually nobody's going
to be allowed to speak because anybody's
going to claim our fence.
And um,
that all the trivializing their
experience of,
of just ended with a funny story.
I mean,
with people like this is somebody
messaged me and he said,
she said,
you should stopped posting pictures of
you smiling on facebook.
And I said like,
yeah,
what's going on over here?
And then she said,
uh,
when you post pictures of you smiling,
you are intentionally trying to
trivialize the experience of depressed
people.
I was like,
lol,
are you kidding me?
And then she like blocked me
immediately.
So,
so,
and eventually the 44 does this person
get attacked.
But other people who may also consider
her trivializing their experience by
like eating food without hand because
they're disabled.
So,
so,
so it just never ends,
never ends.
And I think,
but I'm very glad that there's now a
counter movement to who are the real
liberals standing against the
progressives.
And um,
because the thing is I want everyone to
be treated equally equally as shitty.
You don't have to treat everyone as
equally great.
Treat everyone equally as shitty.
That would be fine with me.
I want women wherever they are to be
treated equal,
whether the United States or whether
they're in Saudi Arabia,
I want gay people to be treated equally
where I want the white,
CIS male to be treated shitty.
That guy can be treated well,
let's hope not.
But uh,
yeah,
I mean that is,
that is,
I mean,
that's what really motivated me when I
started my activism is,
is literally,
I mean,
the movement that I started is called
the global secular humanist movement in
which after seeing so many conflicts
about sectarianism and religious
extremism rising up,
is that the best way is to create a
sector of society,
secular,
liberal society in which all people,
regardless of race or gender or sexual
orientation would live equally without
saying that,
oh,
because it's their culture and things of
that sort.
Because,
I mean,
my,
uh,
motto as humans have rights,
cultures and beliefs,
don't todd rice and yeah,
ideas that should be up to criticism and
debates and human eyes have to be
sustained all across the board.
Well,
all right,
well that's a beautiful ending.
You will always have my support.
Well,
thank you.
And I think,
uh,
I think we're onto something because
when,
even when I was tweeting that you were
coming on,
people wanted to hear this and I think
you're right.
Even though there's a lot of bad stuff
going on,
there is some hope there and that there
was a lot of signs of hope and and I
think your show is one of them.
Alright,
well I appreciate that you guys can
follow Fi's with Feisal Alma Matar on
the twitter.
Hi.
Thanks for watching.
Everybody will do it again next week.